she's right I'm a look at your blog bra  he turned his head he look me straight  in the eye he was scanning the horizon  no I am awaited  hey yeah I'm okay and you how'd you get  the wife to let you go back to work once  she realized that she couldn't  understand what the Real Housewives of  Milan were saying she begged to go re  i'm not going back to work Vinnie I'm  going back to be the king of Hollywood  but I agreed to live by all of my Queens  rules good no you don't you just fight  with me you keep all this chaos so you  can pretend that she never existed no  Quinn I see her every single day when I  look at you  this is what I've got world it's hideous  but it's mine this was her hey how'd you  get that picture of me I look amazing  hello doppelganger she was the only  person I could have a trust well here's  to your mom to my mother and to you and  here's to you I mean you may never be as  wise as an owl but you're always be a  hoot to me